[Musique]
ça un jour en marchant dans une rue de
lausanne en suisse
je vois cette jeune femme en train
d'écrire sur un mur alors je vous le dis
tout de suite moi j'aime beaucoup qu'on
écrivait qu'on dessine sur les murs jeu
toujours très attentif à ces petites
expressions comme ça un peu cryptique
que vous voyez sur les murs de nos
villes
sauf que là elle était en train d'écrire
consciencieusement mon sujet de
recherche
ce pourquoi je me lève tous les matins
et alors vous vous imaginez ma surprise
alors je m'approche des de judy fin je
lui demande avec un air un peu ahuri
qu'il a fait quasiment par j mais
pourquoi pourquoi cette définition
pourquoi vous faites çà et là elle
m'explique très calmement que elie
beaucoup de choses et qui a souvent des
mots qu'elle ne comprend pas alors elle
cherche la définition et puis elle se
dit et à raison d'ailleurs que elle est
peut-être pas la seule à ignorer ce que
veut dire ce mot transhumanisme alors ça
pourrait être utile de l'écrire sur un
mur pourquoi pas ce que je vous propose
c'est de nous livrer à un exercice au
fond très simple essayons de partager un
peu de la perplexité de cette jeune
femme
admettons que nous non plus nous ne
savons pas très bien ce que c'est que
cette affaire le transhumanisme et est
d'ailleurs très franchement moi non plus
je sais pas très bien ce que c'est ça
fait des années que je travaille là
dessus et il ya toutes sortes de
définition contradictoires et même les
transhumanistes mais ne sont pas
d'accord sur la définition toute façon
la plupart du temps on leur demande même
pas leur avis et donc elle est rare
cette perplexité et surtout dans un
paysage dans un débat extrêmement
polarisé où on devrait prendre parti on
devrait toujours contre on devrait
décider si c'est bien ou mal
alors cette définition
cette définition de du transhumanisme et
les bons elle est assez général mais
elle donne des bonnes pistes pour
comprendre de quoi il s'agit
vous avez trois éléments tri dans un
même courant intellectuel et culturel
des sciences des techniques et des
croyances
et ça c'est très important pour
comprendre ce que disent les
transhumanistes c'est à dire ça nous
concerne toutes et tous collectivement
c'est pas réservé à des scientifiques
wade ingénieurs de la silicon valley où
je ne sais quoi
c'est d'ailleurs la plupart des
transhumanistes ne sont pas des
scientifiques des ingénieurs ce sont des
militants et c'est d'autant plus
important parce que nous avons
l'habitude d'entendre dans notre société
que il y aura des lignes de démarcation
très claire entre la science qui ne
serait que la recherche désintéresser de
la vérité la technique qui ne serait que
l'application de la science et des
croyances qui n'aurait surtout rien à
voir dans toute cette histoire
alors maintenant augmenter l'humain
vaste projet peut-être un peu vagues
peut-être fantasque vaste oui mais pas
si vagues si l'on en juge par les
innombrables je sais pas débat émission
de radio tribune colloque universitaire
audition parlementaire
l'humain 2.0 bâton basculer dans une
nouvelle ère une ère de cyborg de post
humain va-t-on devenir immortel avec
quelles conséquences
va-t-on pouvoir s'injecter des
encyclopédies ou des langues étrangères
dont directement dans le cerveau
va-t-on devoir fusionner avec la machine
au risque d'être détruit va-t-on devoir
inventer de nouveaux droits pour les
robots qui seraient des êtres conscients
ces robots vont-ils nous détruire nous
voler nos femmes nos hommes devenir de
meilleurs partenaires sexuels on sait
donc qui n'a jamais rêvé de paramétrer
son partenaire sexuel les machines vont
elles faire disparaître l'emploi plongé
l'humanité 2 une aire de d'ennuyer de
chômage généralisé l'humain 2.0 c'est
pour demain ou pour après demain alors
manifestement le transhumanisme envahi
le débat public avec des formes et des
couleurs très bien défini et tout ça
produit beaucoup d'inquiétude
je suis pas là pour vous dire que ces
inquiétudes ne sont pas légitimes
ce que je voudrais vous dire plutôt
c'est que nous ne sommes peut-être pas
assez inquiets ou panne de la bonne
manière
au fond toutes ces annonces produisent
un sentiment d'impuissance assez
confortable ça nous concerne mais on
nous produisons des récits qui nous
tétanise alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire vous me direz puisque bon c'est
loin de 1045 la californie des
scientifiques nous prédisent qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
eh bien on peut prendre soin des récits
qu'on se raconte
individuellement et collectivement et
aujourd'hui en effet nous vivons dans un
monde qui est saturé d'objets
technologiques surpuissant des
supercalculateurs des voitures autonomes
des petits robots qui vont sur mars
ou plutôt c'est le discours au sujet de
ces objets qui est omniprésent un
discours qui les embarquent dans une
temporalité assez étrange où ils sont à
la fois pour demain dans un futur
surdéterminée urgent il faudrait
inventer toutes nos institutions et nos
modes de vie pour les accueillir et en
même temps un futur assez abstrait assez
vague
on sait pas si est née quand ce sera
possible on se raconte un monde dans
lequel les objets techniques ne sont
intéressants que pour leurs conséquences
sur l'état des choses présent où ils ne
sont que des interfaces ou des outils
qui devraient répondre à l' usage pour
lequel ils ont été conçus et en faisant
ça on dépend dans le vent la pl
l'épaisseur des objets techniques ont
produit ce que l'écrivain de science
fiction des vitrines appelle des récits
fénéon on peut par exemple parler de
l'économie numérique qui nous inquiète à
cause des données personnelles par
exemple on en parle comme d'une économie
dématérialisée alors certes lusage de
nos prothèses électroniques a une durée
de vie très restreinte mais les
matériaux auxquels mobiliser les déchets
les impacts écologiques et sociaux sont
à dhl géologique pétrole métaux rares
toxicité exploitation alors parlant
prothèses par l'augmentation humaine est
le premier mot qui vous vient peut-être
à l'esprit c'est cyborg
mais savez vous d'où vient ce terme de
cyborg
avant de hanter la science fiction et
les jeux vidéo le cyborg est la réponse
à un problème on né en 1960 très peu de
temps avant le premier vol spatial
habité par youri gagarine et on
s'inquiète on prévoit d'envoyer des
humains dans l'espace c'est à dire dans
un environnement qui n'a d'environnement
que le nom puisque toutes les conditions
de vie implicite auquel nous sommes
habitués sur la terre ne vont plus du
tout soit l'alimentation l'oxygène
l'accès à la nourriture et donc il va
falloir encastré c'est humain dans un
dispositif technique très élaborés et en
même temps très fragile puisque comme
vous le savez un accident est très vite
arrivée et deux scientifiques
manfred klein sénateurs klein propose
d'inverser totalement le problème est de
se demander comment on pourrait
implanter dans le corps de manière
automatique des dispositifs techniques
qui permettent de prendre en charge ses
fonctions vitales
la respiration l'alimentation etc et ils
inventent un nouveau mot cyborg qui est
la contraction de savannah tic
organismes et qui est une sorte de
fusion entre la machine et l'humain
l'enjeu du symbole ils le disent
noir sur blanc c'est d'éviter que
l'humain ne devienne un esclave de la
machine on compte en vérifiant sans
arrêt que ces paramètres fonctionne et
de donc le rendre libre de faire ce
qu'il sait faire de mieux explorer créé
pensée et ressentir en 1960 à part les
premiers simulateurs cardiaque qui
commence tout juste à être implanté y a
pas grand chose qui permet concrètement
de réaliser ce projet il n'y a pas
beaucoup plus de choses aujourd'hui
l'enjeu c'est vraiment do vl est
possible de spéculer sur qu'est ce que
ça pourrait être
et cette proposition du cyborg elle est
à la fois très novatrice puisqu'elle
imagine vraiment une fusion entre
l'humain et la machine et en même temps
elle reste assez conservatrices et le
réactualisant fait une rhétorique qui
date au moins du 19e siècle et de
l'industrialisation où on voit la
machine de plus en plus perfectionnés
comme capable d'émanciper l'humain de le
libérer et de le rendre plus capables de
ce qu'il sait faire de mieux penser
ressentir créés etc
en même temps cette proposition du
cyborg passe sous silence toute une
série d'autres détermination du problème
elle ne remet pas en cause la nécessité
de se livrer à une conquête spatiale
militariser la lutte entre les deux
blocs
on est au début de la guerre froide je
vous rappelle elle ne re questionne pas
non plus la nécessité d'être efficace
performant dans un environnement dégradé
alors évidemment l'environnement de
l'espace c'est très simple soit vous
adapter soit vous mourrez mais sur terre
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ce cyborg
parce que comme vous savez j'ai pas
besoin de vous faire un dessin mais
l'environnement sur terre et lui aussi
de plus en plus menaçant alors pendant
de nombreuses années
pendant toutes les premières années où
je travaillais sur ces sujets là il y
avait un personnage qui était
omniprésent dans toutes ces discussions
qui incarnait à lui seul la difficulté
assez classique de distinguer ce qui est
de l'or de la médecine
traditionnellement la réparation de
l'humain et ceux qui seraient dès lors
de l'augmentation des performances ou de
l'amélioration de l'humain oscar
pistorius est né handicapé il a été
amputé des deux jambes à l'âge de 11
mois
et comme tout être humain ayant accès à
des soins médicaux
il a été équipé de prothèses lui
permettant de marcher puis de prothèses
lui permettant de courir et de courir
assez vite pour plonger les instances
internationales du sport dans toute une
série de controverses qui ont duré
plusieurs années et qui ont fait
beaucoup de bruit comme beaucoup d'écho
médiatique
la question était de savoir si on le
laisse comme ils le demandent courir
avec les valides comme par exemple aux
jeux olympiques
est ce que ces prothèses vont l'avantagé
injustement ou est-ce qu'elles vont
simplement compenser un handicap jeu
égal que le meilleur gagne
vive le sport dans ce débat à la fois
les prothèses son coeur de la discussion
mais en même temps elles sont rendues
invisibles par une obsession de la
performance une obsession de la
redéfinition des critères de
main valide et puis par les sponsors la
gloire etc
mais il ya un autre pistorius un
pistorius qui tous les jours est
confronté loin des caméras dans un
contexte intime à son état d'handicapés
chaque fois qu'il doit mettre et enlever
ces prothèses de jambes et c'est le
tribunal de pretoria qui en quelque
sorte tir ce contexte en team en pleine
lumière dans des circonstances hélas
évidemment tragique puisque le tribunal
doit juger pistorius pour le meurtre de
sa compagne rivas tin cup le 14 février
cette fois ci la question est de savoir
en fonction de la hauteur des impacts de
balles dans la porte de la salle de
bains qui sépare la chambre se tenait
pistorius et la salle de bains où ont
été tués les stingers ont fait venir la
porte d'un salle d'audience avec les
experts de la balistique et c'est la
question de savoir est ce que pistorius
était sur des prothèses lui permettant
de faire toutes sortes de choses de se
battre de fuir d'aller chercher de
l'aide de se cacher ou est ce qu'il
était par terre vulnérables terrifiés en
état de légitime défense comme il le
prétendait lui même et lors du procès en
appel son avocate lui a proposé de
montrer sa vulnérabilité à la cour alors
ça pas très bien marché parce qu'ils
étaient condamnés encore plus lourdement
qu'au premier procès mais dans ce
contexte dans ce drame tout à coup les
prothèses sont prises dans un contexte
fait plus plus complexe plus
contradictoires et au présent pas au
futur est véritablement si on déplace la
question de la performance de l'humain
vers l'objet la chose qui se trouve là
qui est caché un petit peu sous une
chaise et bien on peut reposer la
question un peu différemment puisque
bien sûr l'homme augmenté compense avec
plus ou moins de succès ce qu'ils
considèrent à tort ou à raison comme un
handicap et la prothèse et cet objet qui
va venir combler cet écart entre
vulnérabilité et performance mais la
prothèse elle même est soumise à toutes
sortes d'aléas et les fragiles
si l électronique n'oubliez pas de
recharger la batterie et donc
le lob l'objet lui-même devient devient
compliqué gagne un peu en épaisseur et
ça nous permet peut-être d'éviter la
situation dans laquelle on se retrouve
très souvent dans le débat aujourd'hui
autour du transhumanisme pour ou contre
dangereux pas dangereux de prendre parti
qui est une citation une situation qui
ressemble un peu à ce tableau de goya
vous avez deux lutteurs occupé à ceyrat
dique l'un l'autre mais ne voir pas
pendant ce temps que leurs quatre pieds
s'enfoncent dans les mêmes sables
mouvants
ce tableau me mettre beaucoup à penser
le fait que très souvent on est embarqué
implicitement dans un rapport aux objets
techniques qui les voient comme venant
du futur de manière naturelle
irrémédiable douce et régulière et il ya
pire que ça même puisqu'on nous
racontent souvent que la technique
serait moralement neutre mais non désolé
la technique n'est pas neutre elle est
déterminée par des choix scientifiques
et techniques certes mais aussi par des
réglementations par des décisions
politiques et les textures et par des
imaginaires elle met au travail des
matériaux elle mobilise des sources
d'énergie et puis à un moment un autre
elle sera utilisée de manière à peu près
inventive elle va produire des déchets
alors l'enjeu c'est par rapport à ce que
je vous disais au début de produire des
discours qui puisse être à la hauteur de
cette complexité des objets techniques
ne pas se demander comment les
apprivoiser comme des petits animaux de
compagnie mais plutôt comment les
accueillir dans leur complexité qui est
débordante qui est irréductible au fond
ce à quoi je voulais vous rendre
sensible et c'est d'ailleurs la question
que posent les transhumanistes puisque
ça nous concerne rappelez vous c'est
notre affaire
collectivement et individuellement et
personne ne leur running cette
prétention à poser les questions
au contraire
ce à quoi je voulais pas pas vous
convaincre mais vous rendre sensible
c'est de ne pas demander des réponses
d'urgence à des prétendus experts mais
de prendre soin des questions que vous
fabriquez de vous demander comment les
compliquer ces questions comment les
enrichir
je vous remercie pour votre attention
m